i'm ryan right i'm jerry welcome to
raisins to see when we give you reasons
to see and maybe not to see Fast and the
Furious part six
let's ride or die
[Music]
reason to see number one the family it's
about family yeah family or my family
turn you back off family I know where
that word is [ __ ] your family if you can
make a drinking game out of this for the
amount of time somebody said something
about family must have been Diesel's
lives for him just smiling it's about
family yeah but yeah it's it's a it's a
good cast that yes it's a great ensemble
like [ __ ] how amazing do these people
work together yeah they all have unique
personalities that are they're all very
charming they're all very funny it's not
like when Vin Diesel Paul Walker not
on-screen really were they whenever they
cut to anyone they're entertaining to
watch they're all entertaining yeah
everyone is rad or fun yeah God Ludacris
and Tyrese dogs are so great together
funny yeah you've got you know the rock
it was so good I know you didn't get a
chance to check out Fast Five yeah but
in Fast Five you know they had the rock
as the villain I didn't think he did a
great job and I thought it's acting
totally improved and what was cool here
is he blended well with this cast yeah
and even now Gina Carano yeah I did and
I didn't realize it was her until
somebody told me today cuz I was
watching it going um why is she here and
then she starts kicking ass and I'm like
that is why she's here do this that's
what's rad too is like there's a lot of
ladies kicking ass in this business up
high and they're hot babes do but it's
not like they stripped down to bikinis
indentified it's know these are like
tough hot [ __ ] I know we had our
differences about star trek into
darkness
yeah but this to me it was like that
right there is a is a full ensemble
working together I absolutely adore just
watching I had a I had a blast do you
know even not having seen a lot of the
franchise just coming down on this one
you know I caught up and it was it was a
blast it was a great time yeah family
here's the rock that's him in almost
every shot yeah he doesn't think we
point his face up it's great to see the
rocket Vin Diesel in those scenes
together you know Vin Diesel being the
buffest Jew in the world
she's eat
a long but the best time yeah the best
cover you're like really - like you're
laughing but I want it to be that cheesy
yeah exactly
it's that thing you're not laughing it
because it's stupid you're like hi yes
you don't like say family again I'm so
again that ending like it ends with them
praying yeah and it's like we just
watched you guys be criminals to ours
and now you're praising God Hooper
pretty sure lots of people have died
because of what you guys had to do
another thing too is like this is the
funniest one I've seen in the franchise
yeah it's it's hilarious I thought it
was really funny to me I wasn't
expecting it to be as funny as so
humorous yeah there's a lot of [ __ ]
jokes and it just amplify the experience
yeah reason to see number two the insane
action vroom vroom vroom vroom there's
so many moments where the characters
like alright I'm about to do this and
everyone be obviously God no no and then
they do it and you're like yes yeah I
love this movie yeah exactly like it's
so like it it's over-the-top it's
ridiculous by the way yeah there's an
especially there's one stunt towards the
end where I literally set out loud like
what [ __ ] and then it was ridiculous
every impossible far out of this world
not realistic moment was me going yeah
that is what I wanted to see yeah right
there it delivers man because it's like
it's just a fun run just act one must
have cost like four hundred million
dollars yeah they're like destroying
London what I was sitting there during
that first big long chase scene and I
was like hey die hard 5 you want to have
a really long opening chase scene that's
how you do that it's super creative
super inventive I get why everyone I
know loves the demo dude it has every
thing it's got car chases gunfights
martial arts crazy chase sequences yeah
like it's it's if it's called fast and
furious and Wow
does it live up to the title if this
movie doesn't beat around the bush you
know like it starts off with like hey
ladies alive yeah I want to recruit you
all right we're gonna London now we're
gonna hook this guy down straight to the
good [ __ ] and you're gonna have a button
who makes it not boring throughout is
you love the cats as well yeah so when
you love the cast and you're watching a
non-stop adventure
it makes for one hell of a thrill run
it's the one movie this year of the
summer that I think because you see like
a lot of movies have been a kind of wish
washing on when it comes to expectations
Iron Man 3 has a very decisive crowd
most people don't like The Great Gatsby
start checking it darkness everyone's
like it's really good but it's not as
good as I want a lot of people are like
it's not as good as I thought it would
be this one I think people are gonna be
very much satisfied yeah delivers it
fast fine if a sticks are perfect
one-two combo on that scene with the
tank oh that was insane like that was
creative that was that see where I had
to sit there and think to myself they're
killing a lot of innocent people right a
lot of innocent people who are just
going about their day are being crushed
like but you have to stop and think for
a moment like there was probably a
family in that who has just been
splattered the perfect macho fest mates
just a resin which is it's the ultimate
action movie and the set pieces the
action it's not just like they're
throwing [ __ ] at you it's creative like
it's it's very imaginative a lot of
these action scenes madness it seems
like somebody was cared enough to have a
good time coming up with this yeah they
really choreographed though them very
well I mean sure it's not the most
believable [ __ ] but the world they
create makes you go yeah
oh yeah love it it all exists in its
universe and me the whole movie
literally was no they're not gonna yes
yes they did they have just I just saw
that they did that how do I feel more
than satisfied that they did that yeah
exactly it knows what it wants to be it
does that thing and it's a blast to
watch
Ryan's Consensus pure popcorn
entertainment is the reason to see Fast
& Furious 6 pure popcorn entertainment
is the reason to see Fast & Furious 6
whatever you expect of this franchise be
prepared to be satisfied series
consensus awesomeness is the reason to
see Fast & Furious 6 awesomeness is the
reason to see Fast & Furious 6 like I
said it's it's kick-ass it's fun it's
funny it's everything you want to have a
good time at the theaters watch it it's
a rad sandwich alright ladies and gents
thanks for checking out our show why
don't you go ahead scroll that comment
box below and tell us which one is your
favorite Fast & Furious movie was it the
first one was it the fifth one or was it
the third one if you save the third one
be prepared to have a lot of people hate
you and if you want to check out more
episodes the reasons to see go ahead and
click this link right here
if you I've seen my
straight-to-the-point review of Fast &
Furious 6 it's a fast review click right
here and if you want to get updated
every time a new review or a video is
out subscribe do she just wanted one you
want to go in and pitcher the second you
hop into your car after you leave the
theaters you're like mmm
that's sweet out of the parking lot you
want you want your drive to be edited
that way when it's like what like like
every driving experience looked like
that rare is the movie where a cop is
chasing these guys and you're like
they're gonna get away you know why cuz
that's what they do best what I was
funny too is like I like that there are
cops but it's just like I think I'm
gonna do
yes stupid got a whole other than never
a concern yeah exactly
this movie's awesome god I want to be
part of this crew in some way you want
to be part of the family
yeah man I want to join the family when
I sit down at the end of the day and eat
barbecue yeah it's the family
[Music]
you